bonsoir gunnell savard va merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france
est ce que le couvre-feu selon vous qui
est entrée en vigueur pour la deuxième
fois en plus d'une semaine hier soir à
minuit va pouvoir tenir quel est le
point de vue de l'azerbaïdjan sur sur ce
point là mais seule chose que je peux
dire que je suis dévasté d'apprendre à
nouveau le bombardement de la deuxième
grande ville de l'azerbaijan ganja par
les forces armées arméniennes
malgré le trêve maneater qui était
conclure entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan qu'on vous l'avez
mentionné
et je vous rappelle que en fait c'est il
a d'autres villes comme bing et yahoo et
d'autres villes qui a été aussi bombardé
qui se trouve complètement en dehors de
la zone de conflit et dans ces villes on
le trouve que des civils et des
installations publiques et beaucoup d d
d orgue enfin d'organisations
internationales compte dans ce
bombardement et la perte des civils
particulièrement des enfants car à gaja
dernière fois il y avait trois parmi les
victimes il avait 3 3 enfants qui est
qui est très très triste alors c'est ce
que disent aussi les les arméniens que
les bombardements continus sur la ville
de stepanakert là où il ya évidemment
c'est arméniens qui se bat pour garder
cette partie autonome
c'est un peu la guerre des mots la
guerre des images on voit bien écouter
on va tenir seule chose que je peux dire
c'est l'azerbaïdjan mais une contre
offensive pour récupérer ses propres
territoires le haut karabagh et les sept
régions adjacentes qui on parle pas
malheureusement occupés sont occupés
depuis 1920 début des années 90 par les
forces armées arméniennes
c'est ça le zone du conflit et
l'azerbaïdjan jusqu'à présent amène les
contre offensives dans ses propos
territoire dans cette zone du cours du
conflit alors récupérer cette zone du
haut karabagh vous l'avez dit depuis 30
ans et un conflit qui est sous statut
quo finalement pourquoi avoir rallumé en
tout cas les braises
il y a trois semaines maintenant c'est
le conflit c'est le conflit gelé depuis
trente ans je vous rappelle qu'il avait
le 4 résolutions de l'oignon qui est qui
était accepté enfin signé en 1993 qui
réaffirme la souveraineté de
l'azerbaïdjan sur ces territoires
occupés et demande le retrait des forces
arméniennes encore une fois en 2008 il
avait l'assemblée générale de l'onu qui
a adopté la résolution no 6 appelant à
respecter et soutenir la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de la
république d'azerbaïdjan à l'intérieur
de ses frontières internationalement
reconnues
et en plus exigent le retrait immédiat
complet et inconditionnel des toutes les
forces arméniennes des territoires
occupés de la république d'azerbaïdjan
et malgré d'autant plus qu'il avait
parlement européen qui adopter quant à
lui à plusieurs résolutions 2010 2000
2012 2015 et qui compte dans
l'occupation militaire des régions
concernées donc le respect de tous et
droit international qui a été jamais
fait par l'arménie est d'autant plus il
avait la provocation de la part de
l'arménien sur le zone de conflit donc
un moment donné trente ans de
négociations sans issue qu'est-ce que
l'azerbaïdjan et le demande
ils demandent l'application de droit
international de récupérer ses terres et
pour qui un million de réfugiés à
d'azerbaïdjan et c'est à dire réfugiés
internes déplacés internes
azerbaïdjanais puisse rentrer sur leur
terre natale
alors est ce que c'est la nouvelle
implication dans ce dossier de la
turquie qui a donné en tout cas quelques
arguments à l'azerbaïdjan pour essayer
de récupérer justement ce territoire en
fait je pense que cette question de
l'implication de la turquie dans c dans
ce conflit on a discuté à la plèbe
plusieurs fois personnes comment
d'ironie la partie turquie et
l'azerbaïdjan
ils n'ont pas confirmé et des on fait
d'autres pays et non plus la
l'implication de la turquie
militairement non peuples dans le monde
mais dans ce cas diplomatiquement ya il
est le support et le soutien
bien évidemment politique diplomatique
et morale de la turquie à l'azerbaïdjan
dans ce conflit est là en fait ça a été
confirmé à plusieurs fois mais dans
aucun cas on parle pas de soutien
militaire est ce que vous pensez pas que
quelque part vous est instrumentalisée
par par la turquie dans ses velléités
expansionnistes
on sait que la turquie a toujours été un
pays ami et allié de l'azerbaïdjan mais
est ce que dans cette histoire
finalement c'est pas un instrument de la
turquie dans aucun cas c'était pas le
cas le cas parce que l'azerbaïdjan et la
turquie ce sont les peuples qui sont
très liés culturellement
vous savez très bien qu'elles sont de
langue qui est très très proches et nous
on a toujours eu en fait le soutien
moral quand j'ai répété tout à l'heure
et politique de la turquie mais pas
d'autre chose que vous avez évoqué
comment ça va se passer et les
négociations c'est que la russie a tenté
de faire appliquer en tout cas un cessez
le feu
vous êtes toujours d'accord pour pour
pour l'appliquer ce cessez le feu est
arrivé à la table des négociations
je pense que l'histoire ils montrent
qu'en fait depuis les années 1992
l'azerbaïdjan il était toujours pour de
résolution de ce conflit par la voie
pacifique
on a toujours attendu pendant trente ans
pour que les résolutions de l'onu soient
appliquées pour que les 1 million de
réfugiés d'azerbaïjan ils rentrent chez
eux et pour que le haut karabagh plus
c'est d'autres régions adjacentes qu'ils
soient libérés de forces séparatistes je
pense que c'est c'est même l'azerbaïdjan
il est en droit de demander de respecter
le droit international
que pensez-vous de des revendications
des populations arméniennes qui
demandent la reconnaissance de
l'autonomie de ce territoire là la
région du haut karabagh plus sept autres
régions cesson la partie intégrante de
la delà de l'azerbaïdjan l'azerbaïdjan
il a toujours il a tendu je vous
rappelle qu'il a trente mille arméniens
toujours citoyenne d'azerbaïdjan qui
vivent en azerbaïdjan donc même après la
guerre et il a et l'europe toujours
comme le président
il a indiqué dans son discours on va
toujours au haut karabagh les
arméniennes lézard bayonnais ils
vivaient ensemble ils vont vivre
ensemble
les ressortissants c'est à dire les
citoyens d'azerbaïdjan de toutes
origines pour l'azerbaïdjan nazaire
bayonnaise ou arméniens ils vont vivre
dans ces territoires comme ils ont vécu
avant merci beaucoup guisnel safarova
d'avoir répondu ce soir à nos questions
en direct sur rt france